Arno's use of quantum physics to smell
at least according to our best theory of
hair smell works now how I know this
work was always a bit of a mystery to me
but I recently learned how they worked
and so I thought I'd make a video about
it when you sniff odor molecules get
sucked into your nose and they get
captured by a layer of mucus and are
then taken to a postage stamp-sized area
on the top of your nasal cavity called
the olfactory epithelium
this contains bundles of neurons
containing special receptor sites which
detect the molecules and send signals to
the brain it has been difficult to know
exactly how receptors work because
nobody has worked out a way of looking
at them while they're in a living nose
you can take them out of a nose and look
at them but then they lose their
structure when they're not supported by
the cell membrane that they sit in it
would be like taking a jellyfish out of
the sea which just collapses into a mush
we know that the sensation of smell is
caused by odor molecules being caught by
the receptor sites which then causes
those neurons to fire but because we
can't directly look at the receptors we
have to infer how they work from
indirect evidence and the two main
theories about how smell receptors work
shape and vibration the shape theory
says that the smell receptors have
specific shapes that fit the odor
molecules kind of like a key fitting
into a lock however this theory doesn't
quite work because we know that we don't
have one kind of receptor for every type
of odor molecule we have about 300
different kinds of receptors but we can
detect about 10,000 different smells so
there's something more complicated going
on the latest theory is that each
receptor is built to fit just one
section of a molecule so any molecule
that has that part will have a similar
smell so any molecule that has a sulphur
hydrogen bond will smell like rotten
eggs this matches with the evidence
because you can get many different
shapes molecules that end up having the
same smell because they've got a similar
molecular group however this theory
can't explain everything though certain
molecules that are made of the exact
same
rubes but I just arranged in a different
way but they smell very different to
each other for example vanillin which
miles like vanilla has all the same
molecular groups just in a different
order to ISO vanillin which is a very
nasty sickly medicinal smell so there's
an alternative theory of smell receptors
the vibration theory in the vibration
model of smell the smell receptor can
tell the difference between different
molecules based on how they vibrate each
chemical bond has a certain resonant
frequency that it naturally vibrates
that kind of like how an open guitar
string always resonates at the same
frequency and so always gives you the
same pitch so different molecules have a
different signature set of vibrational
frequency which depends on what atoms
they're made of and how they're all
connected in the past scientists have
harnessed this property to figure out
the chemical composition of molecules
using light in a process called Raman
spectroscopy when you shine laser light
through a bunch of molecules some of the
lights absorbed to make these molecular
bonds vibrate and then light with
different energy and hence a different
frequency is emitted you can then look
at the frequencies of this new light
which we see as their color and work out
what the molecules are made of and it's
worth mentioning that when it comes to
light each specific color relates to a
specific frequency which has a specific
energy there's a one-to-one mapping
between them this has been a great way
to detect different kinds of molecule so
perhaps well smell receptors are doing
something like this but many years the
vibration theory of smell was not very
popular because there's no way our noses
can do Raman spectroscopy as
unfortunately our noses don't emit laser
beams and we can't be using natural
light because we can smell in the dark
but there is another method to detect
the vibrations of molecules that uses
electrons instead of light which comes
from the realm of quantum physics it's a
form of quantum tunneling quantum
tunneling is the phenomena where quantum
particles like electrons can travel to
places that normal classical particles
can't they can jump through walls by
disappearing from one side and me
appearing on the other this is one of
the counterintuitive behaviours of
quantum particles and is a consequence
of quantum particles behaving of spread
out waves in a specific situation
electron tunneling can actually be used
to find the resonant frequencies of
molecules if we take two metals and
separate them by a small barrier and
then apply voltage to make an electron
get pushed to one side normally in
classical physics the electron can't get
across this barrier but if the gap is
very small it can quantum tunnel to the
other side but there's an additional
condition an electron in a metal is a
certain energy and it can only tunnel to
the other side if there's an empty hole
which has got the same energy but if the
hole on the other side is at a lower
energy the electron can't tunnel because
there's nowhere for the spare energy to
go but if we introduce a molecule into
the gap something interesting happens if
the energy difference between the
electron and the hole is just the same
as the energy needed to vibrate one of
the resonances it's the molecule then
the electron is allowed to tunnel across
and it drops its extra energy into
vibrating the molecule when it goes
across scientists have built machines
that use this property to probe
molecules the technique is called
inelastic electron tunneling
spectroscopy you can put in different
molecules change the energy difference
between the electron and the hole and
see where the electron tunnels which
tells you about the resonances of the
molecule and so tells you what it's made
from so perhaps our nose is doing the
same thing
perhaps our smell receptors behaving
like that metal and the gap which is
waiting for an odor molecule to come in
which allows an electron to pass across
the receptor and trigger the nerve to
find out scientists did some very clever
experiments this theory makes a very
specific prediction that the odor of a
molecule depends on the frequencies it
vibrates at so if you could change the
frequencies of a molecule you would also
change its smell so that's exactly what
they did they took a molecule but
replaced all of the hydrogen atoms with
a heavier form of hydrogen called
deuterium which instead of having one
proton in the
nucleus we've got a proton and a neutron
deuterium has all the same chemical
properties as hydrogen but is much
heavier the scientists got a bunch of
the normal molecules and the heavier
deuterated molecules and got different
subjects to sniff them to see if they
could tell the difference
humans fruit flies and white fish they
found strong evidence from these
creatures that these two different forms
of the molecule actually smells
different this is really cool because
it's really good evidence of our noses
use quantum physics to smell the world
which i find utterly amazing quantum
physics shouldn't play much of a role in
our warm complicated bodies so it's
crazy that it does but as successful as
the vibration model is it can't explain
everything you may have heard of chiral
molecules which are molecules that are
made of all the same stuff but arranged
as mirror images of each other
for example carvone has a left-handed
and right-handed form because these are
made of the same atoms and bonds they
have all the same vibration so we'll
look identical to vibration tests like
raman spectroscopy and in elastic
electron tunneling so according to the
vibration theory they should smell the
same but they don't one form smells like
caraway or dill and the other smells
like spearmint so what can we conclude
from all of this it seems like you need
both the shape model and the vibration
model to explain how we smell perhaps
our receptors first check the shape of
the molecules and then if they get past
that barrier they're checked for their
resonance vibrations through quantum
tunneling but we won't know exactly how
this works until we can figure out a way
of directly observing the receptor sites
in action but isn't it crazy to think
that these experiences of smell we have
of a flower or coffee or freshly baked
bread or a newborn baby this experience
of the world came to your brain through
something as strange as quantum
tunneling so quantum physics which seems
for many people to be so strange and
abstract well it's going on right up
your nose
just like all my other videos I've made
a poster for this one you can either buy
it or get it for free check in the
description to see where to get those
also if I've made any mistakes in this
video which does happen I put that in
the description too so if you spot
anything check there and if it's not
there then leave a comment and I'll
address that other than that I'm going
to be making a ton more video is now
under the banner of domain of science so
I'll see you on the next one